this canopy mouse is enjoying the
bountiful benefits of living in a
tropical rainforest where food is
plentiful and you can drink right out of
a flower of course there is the
occasional mouse devouring boa to worry
about the Boas flicking tongue tastes
the victims presence the boa has the
mouse trapped high on a limb with no way
out as the BOA moves in for the kill the
mouse seems to be doomed how can our
plucky hero ever escape this impossible
trap
[Music]
spreading its limbs like a parachute the
mouse crashes through the foliage
hurtling the equivalent of six storeys
to earth no human could survive a fall
like this but the mouse well it's as
fresh as a daisy your next flight should
have a landing this soft